previously on farming simulator it's
owned by us baby he's waking up look in
the top right thousand monies I'm gonna
go get a better whatever you are no it's
for unn topped beats it does all of it
oh that's unfortunate
ah I'm guessing what we need is just a
better tractor then right well there was
no mark that's why we have to cultivate
crops there's weeds it's fine it's
clearly not are they are they gonna be
like weeded up beets now are they gonna
be worthless what's the deal I don't
know we got we got a weed it well maybe
we don't it seem to be harvesting fine
one yeah oh I'm fine
look you're not seeing what I'm seeing
there's weeds maybe hire that worker
back and have them hand to pick the
weeds or something I don't know just
tell them I have you're worried it's
fine I'm just harvesting and it's it's
working out fine the weeds are
apparently doing nothing to make a
difference so it's all good this tractor
leaves a lot of tire tracks yes vehicle
tool that's been okay okay we're
returning stuff well return oh hell yeah
yes a laser see Rd see our laser don't
worry about it
farming lasers no I'm about to go drop
off the beets that we got we've got a
full load coming in and we can change
the controlled Driving's this makes this
expensive tractor makes loading
attaching really
Oh does it it does it's like a dream
don't plant beets
I want beets what are we doing we better
be doing beets grass
okay crashed we making money boys China
saying we need cedars China saying all
kind of nonsense maybe we got $10,000
you are welcome everybody
you are welcome but we're in it now
we're in it we're not doing turnips [ __ ]
you guys yeah turnips are for nerds wait
all of our equipment is catered towards
beets the chad is telling we're doing
beets we should do beets we have
equipment for beets we're doing beets
I'm making an executive decision Thank
You boss lord
we're gonna need beet seeds or whatever
a palette of beet beet stew plant
why don't we just plant the beets we we
have did we sell them already I sold
them then that's probably why all right
farming is terrifying you're just a baby
oh yeah I'd rather be a baby than a Marc
slow do not go there you are not ready
for the consequence all day you are not
wired for the karbix go to the wolves
you I'm warning you only a few more
times
just a little bit of effort from you all
the damage to our tractors you have gone
I can't wait to see how horrible the
field looks when I get here well all
right hang on what the [ __ ] is this I'm
working on yeah okay please tell me how
I'm a baby whenever I Drive back we were
gone for 20 minutes this looks like this
property's been abandoned for ten years
I never called you a baby you're just a
baby well I did call you Marc slow yeah
well yeah you you are a liar literally
the entire world can see the evidence of
my lives right now and now literally
destroying our field no they're not
they're pooping therefore they're
fertilizing yeah good right bird poops
good even Bob agrees with me now what's
that stupid machine you got what do you
think that's gonna do for us this so you
were driving it so it looks stupid
because you were there because you look
stupid hmm look boys what I look at it
what is that it is a cultivator don't be
distracted Bob this is the field we left
mark in charge of even though it looks
very awful right now look I'd love to
pile on with the random [ __ ] talking
when I'm busy mixing all of this
oh we might need the big boy tractor for
this hang on hang on I just need to come
at this from the radio
oh no that why are there unharvested
beats my god I'm getting to it did you
left me with like three-quarters of the
field we did not yes you did
and you are distraught you just rammed
our random little tractor out the way
this yeah Wade can you get your stupid
tractor out of the stupid way we need to
figure out how we need to get beets what
do you mean what you need to get your
pie things to plant we need to buy sugar
beets from somewhere well we have one
who's someone else needs to go to the
store or something in it so they're not
suitable for planting or whatever I
don't know man
we need [ __ ] to plant I don't try to
figure out where the [ __ ] to go from
here you go to the shop near this shop
to say that you motivated yes there's
only one cultivated did you cultivate
here look at the strip of delicious dark
dirt over here
that's nice dirt what does that do it
means we can plant [ __ ] in it I think
okay then how do you guys drive it
straight lines just don't touch it I'm
not trying to make weird lines I'm
really trying to like get everything I
just it's like however I play pac-man I
always leave things behind and it's
always comes bites me in the butt but
it's not like I'm choosing to do it the
ghosts are preventing me too from doing
it do you want to do it again but this
time in a way that makes sense I said it
everyone understand we have talked about
listening we won't understand you who
don't you I will not tolerate okay good
I'm glad I'm glad we agreed that if I
don't you will not you
I don't know what you're threatening me
with or 400 but you think oh it's gonna
take me forever to get these little
things what are they worth it
trade me jobs no you right now no I
don't even get out of your tractor yeah
unhook that [ __ ]
give me the harvester you take this
thing my little tiny tractor is not
equipped for this hang on
G it's Q all right no I needed to switch
tools oh I'm on a completely different
level of farming simulator because I got
two tools so I gotta know how to switch
between them how do i back up Oh God
straight lines I don't understand
oh okay I just realize if you don't turn
it doesn't go we're yeah yes you can
just play it directly from the planter
and it'll just take the money away as
you're doing it God really really
interesting I would not have guessed
that I can't turn I don't know how but
mark did you buy a big tractor medium
tractor little tractor big the biggest
one this is hard do I have to go this
direction can I go cross II Wasi Oh Oh
what is like pulling teeth is like
sitting during the SAT this is awful
mark you have the biggest funnest
tractor there is but it's like it's
limited on speed based on the tool like
it's like the tractor doesn't matter is
this the one I just get a tractor don't
matter it don't matter all right well
this is big it's got twin wheels is that
what we want that's what mark says
Mark's tractor right we're splurging
here the twin wheels don't make a
difference it just makes it too wide and
then you can't go anywhere
oh my god I'm stuck on a tree I can
barely move that thing and I was doing
it more effectively than you or I you
are a liar I am NOT a liar there's video
evidence that I am a truther I had a
moment of genius I sure
good luck and a thought popped in my
mind completely of my own volition that
I can change the steering mode of this
thing I am in fact incredibly smart no
oh god no no no no no I left the strip
oh oh no no no you are literally going
to pray that's awful you're totally
ruining our neighbors field
they're absolutely to that poor man's
field the Hendersons deserve it
how did you leave that tiny shitty
little strip
I don't know I'm crab steering i'm crab
steering I hold it early crap stick oh
my god that's terrifying
I might not happening I'm crab steering
because I said that depressed yes of
course
can't you tell No all right I think I
got enough of the beats I'm officially
done with this [ __ ] I told you damn it
you can see how it's crab steering and
it just did the I don't know how to
refill it does it have beats in it now
please please yes please
so bring it on over here and see if we
can let go some plants and beats I can
I'm gonna get in the trailer truck and
go sell this the beats that we have left
and then I guess see if I can do
something to know bring them knowing
that over no god no we're going to
officially be slower than Wade who just
had to figure out how to use the store
no
which is an abomination in this game for
a seed crab searing is a mistake oh hey
wait please please always don't
I am so vulnerable right now no no no no
your front tulip you crazy man I don't
know is it down yes no no no that's the
that's the back jewel got it got it got
it got it it's soaked up I can't do
truck-trailer stuff I can't turn right
go left turn left go right turn no no no
hang on I'm not joking I can't do this
it's okay with no hands right now oh my
god what's wrong with you on it I've
done it I've done it
I was joking the whole time how do I
straighten out there we go I was just
joshing with you get it's not down it
hasn't been doing wait start planning on
the part that's ready to go
it's all a bit I'm just pretending
hahahaha the joke funny joke thanks man
thread the trees thread the trees no
again I have no sympathy I'm out of
sympathy for you my good sir it won't
fit through the tree well what does that
what lesson are you supposed to learn
from that yeah but it can fit through
the trees but what did you just say
before that but it can fit oh no no no
no no no what'd you say before that
hold it I can fold it fit through the
trees all right we just made $2,700 babe
that's not as much as I think yeah well
it was the stragglers it was it was just
the last and final run you know
oh yeah Chet is saying you should just
hire a worker because you're incompetent
mark I had it the incompetent part but
I'm pretty sure that's what they meant I
don't think that's like to have a worker
mark I am doing something do you see how
much of the field has been can I contact
your man your agency I'd like a better
temp no how do farmers do this normally
without like going around the
countryside try on turn around
Bob listen we can't come from a place of
common understanding and appreciation
huh we all have strengths and weaknesses
I can't do the truck thing but I've got
this flowing well get er done then
buddy's almost done I two more passes
this this thing is done it does matter
we've managed to lose a quarter million
dollars that's our one accomplishment I
think but we've gained each other's
trust I don't trust you even a little
bit so that we need to like water this
or something Oh party [ __ ] ears around
what it's it's or II watered dirt I've
discovered something you can tip your
tutorial what's in a tutorial learn to
trade over real good then mock my words
you can mock my actions but not my words
oh hey Mork
and she's done I've done your proud boys
good job buddy
boys I did you proud to fold this up
folded thank you thank you these big
tractors the turning on them is
definitely little wonky mark I got to
give you props for that thank you that's
all I've ever wanted was your props I
figured Oh give him props we've given
him props for what you know I gotta
return your props don't worsen my BOB
caught in the ears they weren't mine to
give
what do you mean there weren't yours to
give wait something was purchased
probably a fertilizer of some point I'd
imagine Bob what was purchased
I got a vehicle okay cool what of it I
mean you've bought like eight vehicles
mark no no at least there's a difference
I don't like I'm getting thoughts in my
head that are saying that we need to
plow but I just plowed so that would be
a logical if you you wouldn't be able to
plant seeds if it wasn't plowed I would
think that was true yeah why does it say
it needs plowing name of the tractor oh
I call it
Faithie Mick squeeze them seeds that's a
good one I don't think that there's a
difference between plowing and tilling I
think it's the same thing when alesis a
forklift dudes is there like a tilling
machine or a plowing machine or you know
isn't that what you just did to the dirt
that's what I thought I just did but it
says it needs plowing does it still say
that on top of the seeds that are
planted yes huh I think if you plow on
top of planet seeds won't you just wreck
the seeds yeah that would be illogical
we would have wasted the seeds that we
put down okay I'm getting confirmation
ploughing is a type of tilling so we're
good I got confirmation cloud no I got
confirmation all right I'm gonna count
that as a victory if somebody wants to
go and pick up oh hey Mark hello we need
we need to drive the forklift back to
like the farm Oh
oh my God look I strapped it in
look-look at my strap I see you straps
that's good straps do we need the
forklift back all right I'll take ya
well I guess the forklift could maybe
live here I don't know well we need to
offload it from the truck maybe that's I
could just unstrap it and open the back
and put it in reverse
that would be equally as effective but
I'll bring the forklift just in case I
Bob I'm coming how do I get this
forklift up if you hold the right mouse
click and move your mouse around you can
you can move it oh why does it hurt my
brand-new universe why would it be
inverse y go up and it go down listen
listen no what do you want do I need to
do it do I need to go no no I got it
oh no if you scratch my new work truck I
swear to god it is the easy answer is
really easy
am i lined up on my live close you can
you can start inching in yeah okay I'm
inching in let's see if you can lift her
up oh all right Oh yep yep yep okay up
all right okay back it out I mean out
tilts her in no Mack you guys okay over
there no Mack and right here here's good
here yet just drop it yeah slam it down
sticky pallidus see there you go well my
job here is done there is a section
that's kind of barren but I can't plant
there so I'm if it was not tilt all the
way or something like it was tilled all
the way I'll do another pass on it
where's the Baron thing just too little
like stretches too little stretches over
here I don't see it I don't know you're
talking about right here knows nothing
because you're trying to tokyo drift off
for it maybe that's not a treehouse I'm
stuck treasure chests absurd not anymore
what it's what was mine not anymore
oh how did you go hi hey that's that not
much will you do me a favor in crowd you
look at my face I don't like where this
is going but uh it's gone
yeah Oh should we buy should we buy like
a house or something or a barn do you
guys want some aminals we can buy yeah
yeah all right meet me at the store oh
you're right animal pen farmhouse
farmhouse right right that's what I'm
saying no here's a question if we buy
farmhouse where the hell does it appear
I think we can place it on the maybe not
sure yeah so if you click it you can
just like place it on the Wow someone
else place the farmhouse someone else
place the farm at was we'd just vanished
I think he became the ghost that decides
where the farmhouse is located oh we can
I mean I could place it but I don't know
if you guys want me to place it oh
please I I'm entrusting you do a good
job sir do it I'm not seeing any tilling
or plowing plows I found um work you you
buy a plow I did well that's where it
goes okay well the whole last house damn
what kind of animals do you want I don't
know man you guys want some cluck looks
some chickens yeah if that's what
cluck-cluck meant guys I want to warn
you before I come in with the plow it's
kind of big sounds good probably yeah Oh
nice house
unfolding plow what is happening oh
that's different than what I thought you
bought the biggest plow that exists can
we buy the land that mark is currently
on with that giant dildo thing this he's
on our land I think so why can't I place
this over here oh maybe he's not on our
level no is this gonna ruin what we just
sewed I'm afraid it is mark I don't know
honestly I'm going for it ah it's
tearing up something I'm not a straight
line I am NOT report I'm not straight
line
I am NOT a straight line what is it
doing I can't see oh it can go all right
i seated that already what are you doing
it wasn't plowed to be fair the game did
say that it wasn't plowed so does that
mean all has to be receded probably well
all right so I can put the chicken coop
down ba ba we're at right now but it's
gonna be like a few feet from this this
field is now plowed nothing is growing
on it the farm lost some land oh no damn
it I hate farming so how why could you
why would you even be able to plant oh
there goes the Hendersons I'm gonna park
our equipment over by the house okay
I'm exhausted you did this to yourself
why so tired allow create fields oh no
oh I'm creating field oh no no what are
you what are you destroying Oh
oh my god you just accidentally
constructed more fields or something I
basically just dug in the grass and it
costs $40,000 mark I can't believe
you've done this
why would chicken eat wheat built eight
seeds don't you feel like watermelon
seed corn or spider-man seeds no no the
hell do you think chickens ooh
those dying big bags do I need for a big
chicken farm don't know to order like
for how many these do I need are you
actually asking me a person who
definitely knows the answer that me
about we know it's all diagonal it's the
wrong way I can't how do you do a
straight line I don't know and I know at
this point I'm not going to help okay
because if I just leave it it turns and
if I turn it it turns can you do 10 once
ah we'll see oh look I'm caught on a
tree
no I'm caught oh no do I need to buy a
chain saw mark to help you out but yeah
you could still hire workers mark that's
that's an option instead of helper F has
completed their task lights
it's so bright mark plus J equals
disaster how much worse can it get for
him wait I'm done oh you're doing great
I'm done there we were lied to
beets are growing without plowing I feel
like I've said like I was fully aware of
that mark what did you do
I cannot wait to see this mark do you
have one of these yes there you go cool
cut down those trees that were in your
way now buddy Gugu you
kill you if you don't kill me it's not
my tree I can't cut it this not my tree
I don't know what I did but I plod the
neighbors slanted what this is Daniel
colors land I don't know
I would touched it and it was gone
you taught you know you did not do that
unbeknownst to yourself I know I'm not
to three squares full of beets growing
and that's it is happening what the hell
haven't dude look I asked for help I
said help no one helped you said I was
on my own I said oh you are on your own
and you were just supposed to not
destroy the entire world I gotta go I
gotta go man hello yes but it's been
real it's been real look I gotta go